KIND OF TRANSFORMATION.
THO YOURCESS.PATH DRIVE, E STAR.
BUE OTHER IS
OMY BUILDER AND WIN E AWARDSEAYR
OKAYAT'S ENOUGH, I WANT TO
BECOME A MOVIE STAR.
AND YOU ENUPN THE MOVIE UMPING .
♪♪♪♪
.ON AGG!
>>IR WHAT DO YOUK WHEN YOU SEE
AMAZED AT MY DRIVE THAT I HAD.BS
S ABSOTHP
I COULD SEVE, I
COULD BE TAT ALL-TIME.
GOT IT.YTNG
YTN 100%
YOD THIS IS WHAT I DID IN ACTIN
LES  THE TI. NOW, AN,
NOT ANU' GMOVI
D  YOU CAN
NEVER BE A MR, BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT TNT
SO YOU FINT VEHICL
ODY AND YOURCCENT,
AN THAT YOU HAD TO DO F E  A
DOUBLE WHO HAD ANYTHING LIKE
YOUR BODY?
>>HIS THE ROM FAE I
GRABBE,  FROM
ONE HORSE TOY HORSE ICUP AND
TY TH AY WT EVERYTHING THAT WA
DO HING
NB
D EN
FINISHED WITH THIS.
I AS
THEY  PAITEMOWILL BE
E WAOUPAIN 1984, YOUR
BREAKTHROUGHE E
TERMINATOR IS THE ICONIC SCENE,
WE ARE
>> I'M A FRIEN SARAH
THA, SEE ASE?>> NO, CAN'T SEES
MAKINGTATEMENT.
>> WHERE IS SHE?
FOUGHT ABOUT HOUTHHAT'S TRUE.AM,
"I WILL BE BACK."ABSOLUTELY WAEA
AND HE "NOI'LL BOR.",  I
BACK IS BETT
IDINGS.ALLY SNAPPED AND HE
O IT
SC?G, TO ACT, DL
OW
BICI  IT BECATHE MOSTREPEATED MN
OR ITHT OF THE IWANT>> NAN
BECAUSE I WA IT. TRIFATHER,
SARGRIVER,
TAKE ME DOWN TO  A
W"ARNOLD, I KNOW
YOU DON'T SMOKE, B LET M
EXPOSE YOU TO SOME GOOD CUN
CIGARS, BUT DON'T TALK ABOUT
." H CUBAN
HIS RUSSIAN
ASNG BIN, D STUFF LIKE
THAT.
FOANT FOME, AND WENG DOWN THERE.
BECOMIN
IT WAS NOT J FN-W,O
BUDDIES BECAG
SOMETHING TOGETHER, G,
WHICH HE WAS ALWAYS A BIG
ERN.ONIFD COS YOUR FATHER
THATOSSM
EIU DECIDE YOU'R
POLITI.
SOF  GETF LIANWONDERVEHE ITHATSF
PEOPLE ITE DECIDED TTRUST YOU
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER, WERE YOU
A LITTLE SCARENG I TU WERE LOOKR
AN OUTSIDER.ED THAT OUTSIDER ALE
RARELY PUTND A TIE.
I KEPT ON MY ALLIGATOR BOOTS.
AL
MY GOD, I'OFFICE,
HAO CHANGEE
SMORS.
OV HUMMER.
I DID EVHIRRECT.E PEOPLE LOVED
BECAUSE THAID, TE
ARNOLD.
HE IS NOGOG TO LSELF,  GOING TEK
.
AN AUESTION, YWAY THE
DRET DED FOR THECELEMEAN THAT..
INMEAR NET
UCED
THAT ENDED YOUR
RR
ING TO HAVE LIMITED THE
YOU KNOWILL  ALSO
ME
A MAJOR FAILURE
I MEAN, I HAD FAILURES IN E
FAILURES, AN OUT ALL THAT? T MA
AND I'M NODESPISE IT.
ANABOUT T I DON'T  TO GE
THIS. THINID
WHEN PEOWATCH IT, THEY WILL
GET IT FINALT'
U'E
MEYO
AT THE MIRROR  WHAE.TURAL EFFEC?
>> KNOW, -ELYOO UNDENDTH
PETING AND SEVENTH MR.IA
MPD  T
NO
MY BODY.NE NOWOW IL
TO WOTEDY
SAFANTASY AND
THAT YOU H
IS THAT BECAUSE ATNOLD SRZCANNOL
I WIL WILL BEIS A FANTASYHAT HF
N TEN
THERE WI
D I BELIEVE INT DON'THINK THAT .
N, YOU KNO
NG.AGE O IDEA
I THINK IT'S VERY SILOFE I'VE D.
LOOK AT THIS LIT'S, EVAB